[Music]
I know
who wants to know more about Harry's son
I really do you think there's a
partridge
and I think it's topping perfect
a lot of people I don't wanna know
Dumbledore do you think that they don't
started
and I think there's probably a good
story there
for birthday
I wanna book a
I wanna book it
and I want to
the epilogue was crap cuz we all know it
was crabbing I want you
say that Voldemort had a son the story's
just begun and I wanted
that she's bragging book
hear the tale a mysterious spell do you
think it's our dimensional portal and I
think serious is even middle-earth
do you think that that's nearly
impossible and I think that's probably a
good story there
I wanna forget
and I watch a caroling said the Apple I
was crap cuz we all know it was crapping
I want a guarantee say that Voldemort
had a son and story just begun and I
want a care
start by tomorrow
storge or head
the mystery or head
if God
okay
[Music]
bah
I really do you think there's an
unwritten story I think it's time to put
fingers two keys for book eight the
first time I saw you us the day that I
hit puberty you played a beautiful girl
shut in my society it was in your fall
you just found one lace to be that
after-school special made me wanna never
do PCP Oh Helen Hunt Helen Hana you make
my heart do acrobatics stunts you stand
and face the brunt of the twister of my
burning want Helen Hunt
allow you I saw you naked
water dance it was as good as it gets in
my pants and for that I really want to
thank you your husband's name was Hank
right well my name is Hank to Helen Hunt
Helen Hunt you make my heart do
acrobatic stunts you stand and face the
front of the twister of my burning one
Helen Hunt you know I'm mad about you
once an ex best friend of mine said he
couldn't see how an old and ugly actress
could mean so much to me well a minute
later looking down at him bleeding in
the snow I asked him who was best comedy
actress four years in a row it was Helen
Hunt
Helen Hunt you make my heart do
acrobatic stunts you stand and face the
brunt of the twister of my burning want
Helen knowledge
about you Oh Helen
about you
you
[Music]
I'm kinda tired of this publication
media blitz II got muddled kinda under
your spell don't you know the whole
what's already gone and reserved a copy
at Amazon how many more could you sell
[Music]
give me my burger Kota
cuz I need Harry Potter like good
it's water that's a turd
I feel death be
getting kind of petrified move on to if
Hermione died or if Voldemort killed
Hedwig just very young
crap that would freak
Harry Potter like a Greenville of these
wandered on Saturday approaches my
Incendia
I pretend
the sleeves up JK rowling I have to do
is typically value can protect out your
blood punch face mouth boy
but in the end I don't think it's gonna
matter it's taste good earth is bad
because the weight of the rest on our
boy
[Music]
the world rests on our goal
Harry Potter's like a green
water net Saturday I'm Rotem I me
father
like feigning tears on remand
[Music]
but mostly I'm just feeling sad I know
this could end real bad but I wish it
didn't have to end it all yeah we care
more about the Harry Potter if Hardwick
was my alma mater
I
sell the farm
Oh
[Music]
I hope you're somewhere warm
like flowers in your car Jews escape
this labyrinth of suffering wherever you
are I got a piece off you tucked away
deep inside my mind memories of you
would she drinking your cheap wine
Thomas Edison's last words were it's
very beautiful
I don't know where there is but I
believe it is somewhere and now hookahs
beautiful like you
you're beautiful I never really knew you
at all
you green eyes to shine with life in
you smell those press the new ants are
still alive at me I found the grief
perhaps in blue citrus and the smoking
hole you're in with my beginning with
the kiss that I stole Thomas Edison's
last words were it's very beautiful
over there I don't know where there is
but I believe it's somewhere
now hope it's beautiful like you
you're beautiful I never really knew
[Music]
we were the storm the game and went like
lightning struck the by surprise with
the laughs I thought you might freak say
I'll forget your boozy breath I can
taste it we'll always have pressed
Franks and
strawberry is Thomas Edison's last words
were it's very beautiful over
I don't know where there is but I
believe it's somewhere
now who is beautiful like you
beautiful and I'm still looking for you
Laska
you
lady at the grocery store
it seemed that you don't know what the
express lane is or it says twelve five
but you're exempt from that I started
[Music]
kill you over 25 cents I'll give you a
friggin border it makes that much
difference and you just remember
something you forgot to get your husband
to be right back with it
I'm gonna kill you and possibly your
whole family - all I want is some
courtesy kindness and maybe an apology
you don't get out of my grocery line
Alou scorpions fatality in the sky not
usually a very peaceful person kill you
[Music]
I just wrote a note
guy down the street recently invested in
a giant SUV it said I hope you know that
we're but no more so you can get your
badass home from the grocery store
better traded
I'm gonna kill you yeah
kill you with a car father yer aged I
don't think it'd be too must ask for you
to be a bit lesser than asks I suggest
you reinvest in a Honda Fit if you don't
you're gonna regret it honour to be a
very people gotta kill you it's 3:00
a.m. and my neighbor upstairs he worse
than our worst nightmares he had some
friends over for some late night River
I see tablets yeah I'm gonna kill you
and all your loud ass friends I don't
think it'd be too must after you to be a
bit less of an ass if I don't get some
peace and quite often - on a strip and
died
[Music]
you